Bloopers are an inevitable part of movie-making.
Like everybody else in the world, actors and
everybody else involved in the movie-making
process are only human.
Mistakes will happen - but it goes without
saying that, as a general rule, most people
would rather watch an actual movie than a
movie's blooper reel.
However, in some cases - either when a movie
is particularly bad or a blooper is particularly
good - the bloopers are actually more enjoyable
to watch than the movies themselves.
That's what this video is all about, so enjoy
it, and make sure you subscribe to our channel
and join the notification squad to receive
alerts every time we upload new videos!
Here are ten bloopers you would rather watch
than the movie.
Spider-Man 3
2007's Spider-Man 3 was a terrible movie and
a very poor finale to an otherwise great trilogy,
and it's safe to say that watching bloopers
from it is more enjoyable than watching the
movie itself.
There are certainly plenty of bloopers to
choose from, including one classic example
of an actor not being able to stop laughing.
Star Wars: Episode I - The Phantom Menace
In 1999's heavily-criticised Star Wars: Episode
I - The Phantom Menace, Brian Blessed lent
his unmistaeable voice to Boss Nass - the
leader of the Gungans, who the Jedi failed
to persuade to help the people of Naboo at
the start of the movie.
In the scene in which he is talking to the
Jedi and their allies, there's a blooper that
is far more entertaining than the movie itself!
Iron Man 3
2013's Iron Man 3 certainly isn't as bad as
some people like to think it is, but it certainly
isn't one of the Marvel Cinematic Universe's
better quality or more entertaining offerings,
which is why it's fair to argue that the movie's
bloopers raise more of a smile than the movie
itself.
House of Wax
Any movie that has Paris Hilton acting in
it is bound to be terrible.
2005 horror House of Wax saw her in one of
her most prominent roles and was, unsurprisingly,
not an exception to that rule.
It was a ridiculous movie that made the original
1953 movie of the same name look like a masterpiece,
so it's definitely more enjoyable to watch
the bloopers.
The Hangover
2009's The Hangover is undoubtedly a great
movie.
It remains the highest-grossing R-rated comedy
of all time - and with good reason, because
it's hilarious.
However, some of the outtakes are even funnier
to watch, with the cast's uncontrollable laughing
being infectious.
Daddy Day Care
Daddy Day Care is one of those movies where
the bloopers are, quite literally, the best
part about it.
The 2003 "comedy" - and we use that word very
loosely - incorporates some of its gag reel
into the credits at the end, and it's genuinely
more entertaining than the previous hour and
a half you have to endure before it.
Movie 43
Movie 43 is an absolutely awful movie.
In spite of its almost unbelievably large
and strong ensemble cast, it is quite literally
one of the worst movies ever made.
Like Daddy Day Care, it features some of its
bloopers in its closing credits - in this
case, it's almost as if the people behind
the movie knew viewers would be dissatisfied,
so they thought they'd throw in a few laughs
to appease them before they left the theatre.
Men in Black II
2002's Men in Black II was undoubtedly the
worst of the Men in Black movies, but it was
still pretty enjoyable.
That being said, with Tommy Lee Jones being
such a straight-laced character in the franchise,
seeing him mess up and subsequently laugh
was always going to be more enjoyable than
watching this movie as a full feature.
Anchorman 2: The Legend Continues
Anchorman 2: The Legend Continues continued
in 2013 where 2004's Anchorman: The Legend
of Ron Burgundy left off.
While it lacked the originality of the first
movie, it was genuinely every bit as funny.
A particularly funny moment came in the form
of Paul Rudd's Brian Fantana showcasing his
condom collection to the rest of the main
cast in his office.
Margot Robbie in Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad was one of the biggest cinematic
disappointments of 2016.
It seemed to have a great cast and a unique
concept for a comic book movie, but something
just didn't click.
That being said, the cast seemed to have lots
of fun on set - not least because of a lot
of fun bloopers.
Those bloopers are a lot easier to watch than
the contrived movie itself.
Thanks for watching our video about ten bloopers
you would rather watch than the movie.
What other bloopers were more entertaining
than the movie they occurred in?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.